hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about Helicobacter pylori and
how it survives in the human stomach so
he'll go back to pylori is a bacterium
it causes peptic ulcers otherwise known
as stomach ulcers it also can cause
inflammation in the stomach or as
gastritis and in some cases it can even
lead to stomach cancer although it's
important for you to remember that about
80% of carriers are asymptomatic so not
everyone who has silica bacter pylori
actually has any symptoms Helicobacter
pylori is also a nutri file that might
surprise you it might surprise you
because I just told you that it infects
the human stomach which has lots of acid
in it so how can it be a neutral file a
bacterium that thrives in more neutral
conditions and is not able to grow in
acidic conditions it actually has an
optimal growth right around the pH of 6
we know that stomach acid is a pH of 1
or 2 so this seems to be a disconnect
how does this work well it works because
h pylori creates a less acidic micro
environment it does this by producing an
enzyme known as urease so it produces
urease which catalyzes this reaction it
takes urea reacts it with water to
produce carbon dioxide and ammonia the
ammonia is then spontaneously converted
to an ammonium ion because water that's
present in the area will donate a
hydrogen ion and so that happens
spontaneously and the ammonium ion is
very basic
and so by producing urease h pylori can
have this reaction happening and and
basically produce large amounts of this
ammonium ion which raises the pH in the
area immediately surrounding the cell
making it less acidic and closer to this
optimum growth pH so now let's kind of
see what this looks like in a picture so
here we have the cells lining the GI
tract and then we have three different
zones the zone up top here is a pH close
to two this is where the gastric juice
or stomach acid is then there's a mucous
layer that's on top of the cells lining
the GI tract and the mucous layer has a
pH that's closer to four that's still
quite a bit lower than the optimum pH of
six though and so what does helical
bacter pylori do well it inhabits this
zone right here in the mucus layer
really close to these these cells that
line the GI tract and remember it's
pumping out each of these cells is
pumping out this ammonia that gets
converted immediately to ammonium ions
which raises the pH of it to the pH of
this layer is more like six to seven so
right in that optimal growth range for
helical bacter pylori and so now you can
understand how it can survive in the
human stomach there's also a cool
diagnostic test for Helicobacter pylori
that is based on this reaction and it
works because the patient drinks a
solution of urea this stuff right here
where the carbon is radioactive I'm
going to indicate that with an asterisk
and we know that if a patient drinks
urea and helical bacter pylori is
present and making urease and is going
to convert that urea with some water
into these products and this carbon
dioxide that's produced will also have
that radioactive carbon so if the
patient who drinks this solution exhales
or breathes out radioactive carbon
sigh then their doctor is going to know
that they have h pylori and their
stomach and can prescribe them some
antibiotics to treat that infection if
you're interested in learning more about
bacterial ph requirements learning about
acidophiles and nutria files and aquila
files and see my video on bacterial ph
requirements you can also check out my
video introduction to enzymes to learn a
little bit more in general about how
enzymes work so that's it for today
thanks for watching biology professor